felicia i want to start with you i just
watched you in black box so i want to
know what it was like for you going from
a horror film to playing such a lovable
character in this magical movie
well i played the lovable character
first
okay gotcha and actually in black box
she was
well a little less than lovable she
meant to be lovable well
that's another story it's two different
people but that's what we do as actors
we assume all these characters
[Music]
but both of your characters are all
about family there you go
there you go don't you want to see her
in more horror
story you
nailed it it was great yes
um madeline i want to ask you is this
your first feature film
yes it is my first movie i that that is
hard to understand because you are so
talented you're so good you're such a
natural
what was it like for you working on this
set with some of the best actors in the
industry
and getting to show off your amazing
voice uh
i mean it's crazy um i'm so
fortunate and so lucky to you know be
able to have
gotten this role um i definitely know
many of my friends
that are in the performing arts world
could have definitely stepped into this
role because they're immensely talented
so i was so grateful to be able to
get this role and work with all these
amazing actors and actresses and singers
it was so inspiring to just watch them
on set in their element
um it was truly every part of this
experience was a blessing
um you posted a really funny photo on
your social media of you looking at john
legend when he came on set who of course
worked on the music for this film what
was it like meeting him
i mean it's mr john legend i don't have
any words i was like
oh my gosh that was mr john legend it
was so crazy
because um actually after i finished
filming
jingle jangle my parents told me that
before i was born the first concert that
they went to
together was mr john legend's concert
wow so that that was definitely very
crazy but yeah it was
insane meeting him it was so cool
um anika you have one of the most
powerful numbers in this
movie it gave me goosebumps um and you
have such emotional scenes with force
whitaker what was your whole experience
like
you know it was fantastic um
christmas is you know one of my favorite
times
of the year christmas music is some of
my favorite music
yeah um and to be in something that is
so
traditionally celebratory
of what christmas is supposed to mean
um was really a gift um
i loved it i loved being able to be
a part of john legend's music catalog
no big deal and we also have phil
lawrence who writes with infor bruno
mars who is phenomenal
um mr whitaker is just a
gentle spirit and a lovely soul
and so it was working with
lovely people it was just working with
lovely people and being able to do
you know what i do on on screen that is
always a gift
well this no doubt is going to become a
classic holiday movie for so many people
so i want to know what are some of your
favorite
holiday movies that you watch every year
uh felicia what about you
polar express that's a good one
i love that one okay madeline what about
you oh
um the live action grinch with mr jim
carrey
oh that's a good one did you have you
ever watched the animated one
yes i have i watched all of them
actually but yeah the live action one
has to be my favorite
that one's good okay nico what about you
so i'm all about the grinch cartoon
and love actually oh so good
it's so good you know at the heart of
this movie it's really about the
strength of family and i feel like in
2020 that's more important now than ever
blisha how important is it to have a
movie like this come out this year
oh i think it's immensely important i
think
it celebrates humanity it celebrates
people
it celebrates family you know and its
meaning and its power and its strength
and what it gives us all
and as uh anika had stated earlier
this afternoon so many people have been
separated from family
and sown permanently you know through
loss and so
this is a gift this is a gift to people
i think
i completely agree well thank you so
much guys congrats on the film i loved
it so much
thank you
you